hey everyone this is good sob I'm a
teacher for free code camp and the goal
of this video tutorial series is to
learn the skills of a senior software
developer so each video will be chatting
with a senior developer and we'll walk
through a specific challenge that he or
she faced and we'll walk through all the
steps that they went through how they
reasoned through to the solution and
finally there will be a call to action
at the end of the video where I'll
explain how to translate the skill as
you see in this video into a solid thing
that you can build for your portfolio so
today we're here with a senior developer
at front row Ed front row is an adaptive
learning software that's used in over
thirty percent of schools in the country
their users include over 200,000
teachers and 4 million students so we'll
be chatting with Alexander Karelin who
is the CTO of front row you're about to
see the part of the conversation where
he dives deep into the topic of
trade-offs so trade-offs Alex explains
is one of the key skills that
distinguishes senior software developers
and what that means is the ability to
look at many different solutions to a
problem understand the pros and cons of
each one and then pick the one that's
most appropriate for the specific
situation that you're in so alex is
going to walk us through a challenge
that he faced a front row where they're
old technology stack and language which
was closure wasn't it wasn't serving
them very well they were facing some
challenges and so we had to decide
whether to stay with that or move to a
new language which was Haskell and so he
walks us through kind of how he reasoned
through the trade-offs of each solution
and why he picked one over the other and
in case you're wondering this in the
background this is the mascot JT the
piggy that stands for Justin Timberlake
and this is me good solid so Alex I
wanted to do a win on one of the points
you mentioned yeah trade-offs yeah I'm
wondering
if there's a decision that you can walk
us through where you had to weigh
different trade-offs like maybe
something like the technology you chose
stack why do you pick Haskell for
example turn now that's a nuanced and
large question which I get asked
actually very frequently because that's
I think very interesting to a lot of
people whenever you do something outside
of the norm that's something you will be
asked about and in our case is we start
with a dynamically typed language which
was closure back a day and you can think
of it as yes it's functional but the
dynamically type portion is very similar
to when you would experience in
JavaScript and removing a Python which
is you're not specifying two types of
the variables that you using you're just
you're specifying especially the shapes
of them and then those can be changed
over time and there's nothing statically
so I've compilation time telling you
whoa these two things did not match
I want to go over some of the jargon
that alex is talking about here dynamic
typing static typing shapes variables
run time compilation time what do all
these things mean so let's take a look
at a dynamically typed language
JavaScript Alec was referring to closure
as a dynamically typed language but the
same concepts apply to JavaScript so
notice we're passing these three things
a date a number and an undefined value
all into the same function print date
and JavaScript allows this the key thing
is this as long as each of these
whatever you pass in as long as it has a
two-string property javascript will
handle it just fine and this is what
Alex meant by the shapes of variables
instead of the actual type now one of
these types causes the program's crash
because the undefined doesn't have a
two-string property and we'll see how
that plays out so when we run the
program in the browser we see oh there's
an error the undefined value doesn't
have a property to string and notice
that we don't find out about the air
until we run the program in the browser
that's called a runtime error all right
now let's look at an example of static
typing we're using a framework called
flow which allows us to declare types
for our variables and here we're giving
today a type of date now again Alex was
referring to a different language
Haskell as a statically typed example
but same concepts apply here to flow um
so now with a statically typed language
we can compile our program before we run
it and it will check for certain errors
and it fine and it tells us that hey you
can't pass in a number or an undefined
value into print date all right so next
Alex goes into some of the details of
the situation at front row which and
we'll kind of compare which of these is
was better for his situation
project was getting progressively larger
and larger so it was it started with
just me developing it and then it
spilled into two or three different
products so we had a have a student
product a teacher product that parent
product is school product and there was
a lot of code reuse between the
different products because you don't
want to don't repeat yourself dry as one
of the core tenants and principles of
solid soft engineering and so being able
to reuse code is actually quite
challenging
so the project was getting larger at
frogro and they were developing multiple
products so they had a teacher product
student product school product and a
parent product and they were all trying
to reuse code so in our simple example
here we are going to have one shared
method that is going to be shared by two
products the teacher and the student
product so here we have our shared
module it has the function is holiday
which takes a month and a day and this
returns weather that day corresponds to
a holiday the student product has this
function by reminder email which will
construct a special message if the
current day is a holiday the teacher
product will prevent the teacher from
declaring office hours on a date that
happens to be a holiday so let's see
this in action here unloading both of
our products here in node and I'm going
to call the right reminder email
function and give it a holiday let me
see it gives that special holiday
message if i do the teacher product and
try to declare office hours on the day
of holiday we again get that special
failure message so notice that this
example here is dynamically typed and
next Alex explain some of the challenges
that you faced at frogro with their
dynamically typed set up so I want to
rewind to the moment when you start
noticing this problem what was the first
time you got the sense that you know
what these shared modules are getting
out of hand we need to switch to a
statically typed language sure what what
was happening is that I would change one
of these internal modules that would
change it at the interfaces and and I
had to put in a lot of extra work there
was a lot of
overhead work that was was not really
good use of my time to update all the
unit tests that were there in place to
make sure that let's say these four
products were using this share
functionality all corrected same time so
now instead of just being immediately
told does make sense this doesn't make
sense I have to go in there first of all
make sure that those tests exists which
is time consuming this is not time
you're spending on working on your
product this is your time you're
validating that the product is sane and
as your Prada gets bigger and bigger and
the permutations become more and more
that's more testing after right and
you're essentially doubling the work of
the compiler but I was doing more and
more of this overhead and that was not
adding any value to the product it was
just me doing something very very
tedious medium got it
so Alex talked about the specific
symptom he started noticing about the
problem the the queue that let him know
that there was a problem whenever he
would change the interface for a shared
module bad things would happen so things
with brain could have to update a lot of
unit tests so let's walk through this
what do we mean by that changing the
interface so an interface is whatever
you need to know about an object in
order to interact with it so for example
what do you need to know about a
computer in order to interact with it
really just how to use the keyboard so
that's the interface when it comes to
code what's the interface for our shared
module well what does student and
teacher need to know about is holiday in
order to use it it needs to know the the
name of the method and the parameters so
that's the interface let's go ahead and
change our interface instead of taking a
month and day as parameters will it'll
just take a date object and then it'll
extract the month and date like this and
now notice what happens when we run the
program we're gonna run student product
we get an error so this is called the
runtime error because it the error
happens as we're running the program can
we do better than that can be some can
we somehow find out sooner than this
that there's going to be a problem and
the answer is yes yes we can with the
help of unit tests so unit tests will
simulate what might happen as we're
running the program so notice here we're
writing these method calls passing in
some parameters and we're checking to
see that the output makes sense we have
unit tests for both the student product
and a teacher product okay notice what
happens when we run our unit tests
everything breaks all four tests break
and this happens before we run the
program and therefore we can find out
that hey something's
broken we can well we can fix that by by
updating our code so we'll update our
students method and our the way we pass
in shared module and then we also need
to change our unit tests this is going
to take in a date object okay and we
would we would change all these unit
tests so this is the symptom that you
would look for in your own code as
you're updating shared modules if you
notice whether you have to update a lot
of unit tests so next I explain why it's
important for you to be aware of this
symptom so the reason I'm asking this is
I'm wondering as the audience what can
they look for in their code base to let
them know what this is the queue this is
the same trigger that Alex noticed and
so what I'm hearing is if you're ever
find yourself doing this very thing over
to write one feature you have to now
expect the unit tests across many other
use cases that might have nothing to do
with what you're writing at that point
you might reason as Alex did that maybe
a statically typed solution language
would solve that headache yeah I would
say there were two two big red flags
here is one you're having to reimplement
almost the same test over and over again
for different products and two things
are maybe you don't have those tests and
things are continuously breaking right
when you're editing these shared modules
so you edited it maybe you fix one
partner project you deployed to
production you discover a few hours
later and make a day later that's
something else broke and you want to oh
I totally forgot that we have this
well that means you don't have enough
test coverage but now we go back to is
writing an infinite amount of tests
really good use of your business's time
so Alex mentioned that with the
dynamically typed language they were
using closure he had to maintain lots of
unit tests 4shared modules as a product
got bigger and a statically typed
solution Haskell solved these challenges
for him so let's take a look at how that
might happen for our example we're using
flow in JavaScript to allow for static
type checking notice it types on the
variables and notice we have a lack of
unit tests that's because our flow
compiler will detect for the same types
of things that our unit tests we're
checking for and we see we have no
errors now that doesn't mean we'll never
have to write unit tests we just won't
have to write unit tests specifically
for detecting when interfaces change on
your shared module so let's go ahead and
try to change an interface here and see
that we get an error so you find out
right away that things are broken and
next Alex explains why this was
important to him the the principle is
you want to anticipate problems that you
want to detect bombs as early as
possible in the process because fixing a
problem once it's a production is it
very expensive fixing it once you said
okay compile the code I just wrote very
cheap it's literally like several orders
of magnitude cheaper to do it sooner
than later so we've talked about the
skill of understanding trade-offs and
we've seen Alex demonstrate this skill
as he thinks through the trade-offs of
haskell versus closure which one is
right for front row and their situation
there I'd like to give a call to action
for each of you to put this into
practice I'd like for each of you to
have a project that you've personally
built that was challenging where you had
to think through the trade-offs of
different solutions and then pick the
one that's right for your situation now
one of the
best ways to caen is to contribute to an
open source project free code camp is an
exciting project they have lots of
things that they would love your help
with to build on their roadmap and of
course I'm biased because I'm also a
contributor to freako camp but they're a
very respected project they've served
hundreds of thousands of people and
they're the most starred project on
github I will even offer a free session
to help you get started and I'll help
you find the specific feature on free
code camps roadmap that's challenging
that would require you to think through
the trade-offs of different solutions
and here's how to get in touch with me
you can set up an appointment directly
on my calendar or reach out to me over
email I love talking about coding happy
to answer any questions you have alright
I hope you enjoyed and until next time